[Musique]
n'existe aucune trace de votre choix
puis retrouver un enfant abandonné son
fils depuis 30 ans c'est très difficile
d'espoir non mais ça c'est normal de
donner c'est donner reprendre c'est
voler je me suis plus que c'est trop peu
juste quoi on peut rien faire alors ça
peut prendre du temps mais c'est à dire
j'ai un soucis de santé
si vous êtes pressé en savoir plus
excusez nous voient surtout si tu lis
qu'on
bonjour je suis strapée j'étais l'agent
ce2 santé discutait pas vous dire ça
madame dit qu'il n'a pas les gens pour
leur demander de l'aide pour a reçu
alors t'es pas non plus de cinq ans ici
on travaille c'est sur moi que je tirais
avons menées à l'intérieur
si tu te reste vive et j'aimerais vous
dire que nantes et maintenant il est en
fuite
en rage si je peux vous aider c'est très
gentil qui joue pas comme si je
retrouvais au dossier
mais très wawa aucun discernement
[Musique]
souple et aux jeunes des médecins oui
j'ai un petit garçon avec vous on avait
un enfant ensemble
[Musique]
drapé dans les tribunes a tempera
veulent changer la vie l'énergie du
british airways ankama et là encore jean
quête d'amour
je t'aime ce sont les mots les plus
importants tire dessus